countries and being split into two name
a more iconic duo and whilst germany
ireland and korea are the most often
discussed another country with such a
divide is cyprus which since the 1970s
has been divided into two parts or three
if you count those that still belong to
britain in the south sits the republic
of cyprus recognised by everyone and in
the north lies the turkish republic of
northern cyprus which is recognised only
by turkey and this state of affairs
raises an obvious question what caused
this to happen why is cyprus divided so
before cyprus was split it was a british
colony which they had acquired from the
ottomans in 1878 and many of those
living there were greek cypriots most of
whom wish to unify with greece in a
process known as anosys however that's
not how empire works and the british
opted to ignore them because cyprus's
position was far too valuable to them
many decades later like most british
colonies in the wake of the second world
war cyprus and its people pushed for
independence in the mid-1950s greek
cypriots began an armed campaign which
wanted to end british rule there and
unify the island with greece of course
the british were happy to accept these
demands and just kidding they teamed up
with the turkish cypriots to fight back
and in the end settled on giving cyprus
his independence and britain preferred
an independent cyprus that wasn't a part
of greece since it wanted military bases
there as a forward base for the middle
east cyprus as a small new nation could
be coerced into agreeing to this in
return for the end of british rule
whereas greece was a much larger
established country that would be able
to resist after the british had left the
island well mostly tensions rose between
the greek and turkish population there
one of the conditions of cypriot
independence was that the turkish
minorities rights would be respected and
also it was agreed that no one would
push for a union with either greece or
turkey nor try to partition the island
and greece turkey and britain all agree
to uphold this status despite the
agreement many greek cypriots including
president macarius felt that the turkish
were overrepresented and so wanted that
changed shockingly the turkish cypriots
didn't want this and so a decade of
impasse in 1974 feeling that macarius
wasn't doing enough a group of the
nurses-backing cypriots aided by the
dictatorship in greece launched a coup
macarios fled and nicos sampson was
placed in charge and made it clear that
he was going to unify cyprus with greece
and now the turkish government was
concerned for the welfare of turkish
cypriots who were subject to growing
violence and so ask britain to help them
intervene and the british said no and
for this they had two reasons the first
was that they were too busy being poor
and the second was that those in
government above all else wanted to keep
their military bases and thus by not
picking aside it was hoped that they
could leverage the fact that they didn't
oppose the eventual winners to keep
their territory on cyprus as a result
turkey opted to proceed alone turkish
troops landed here and they very quickly
and easily pushed greek cypriot forces
back across the island this was
condemned by the united states who
didn't want two nato members going to
war and breaking the alliance but
generally most countries were
sympathetic to the turkish all of this
embarrassed the military government in
greece and fears over all that war led
to the collapse of the regime there
whilst the greeks were busy becoming a
democracy again the turkish opted to
push even further across cyprus at this
point the rest of the world turned
against turkey since this was now seen
as little more than territorial
expansion as such the turkish british
and greek governments met to end
hostilities and a ceasefire was agreed
the turkish military stayed in the lands
that it had taken and the united nations
would construct a demilitarized zone
running across the island and it was
hoped that with the greek back coup over
in the violence diminishing turkey would
leave but fun fact no instead the
turkish created the turkish cypriot
administration which would run the
territory the turkish had captured and
in the wake of the creation of this
administration many greek cypriots were
forced out of their homes and cleared
from the north and in the south many
turkish cypriots were also made
unwelcome and forced to head north and
in 1983 the turkish cypriot government
there made a unilateral declaration of
independence which was condemned by
everybody except for turkey pakistan and
bangladesh and the last two were soon
pressured into withdrawing their support
leaving only turkey supporting the north
but irrespective of international
support the island still remains divided
to this day
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly moneymaker corso wolfe jordan
longley adam stalter jerry lambda in
marcus arsenal y in hockey words about
books podcast rodney martin captain
cydog marvin cassel gustav swan spencer
lightfoot boogery wiggly common yoon
winston k wood aaron the white matthew
shipley alex schwinn maxson flaudio
maggie patzkowski anthony beckett the
mcquapper corey turner copper tone
spinning through plates charles the
first ben evanson and scottish trekkie